oh yeah i feel like most people there's
two types of people that go to the
groundlings once you
are like convinced they're going to be
on snl i want to go to snl that's it
you're not even thinking mad tv you're
like i'm going for snl now who wants to
go mad tv or i mean at the time sure i
would love to
or
people who are just trying to
come out of their shells or who are like
bosses
at an office and they need to be able to
express themselves so they want to
just kind of do improv so they can
think on their feet and
company meetings and stuff
i was like and i remember
when i was
like 18 or 19 i called the groundlings
office this is from riverside because i
knew
they had a bunch of people on snl who
were
from groundlings or second city
and i wasn't going to go to chicago or
toronto so i called the groundlings
theater just cold called him at like i
was probably 19
and a woman answered and she's like
groundlings theater and i go hey how do
i i want to be in your theater i want to
be in your company
she's like okay well um you have to sign
up for classes and and you start at the
beginner level and i did that i took it
i did too and she goes
and she's like so you there's four
levels of classes and i go
what i go how much are these and she's
like like 250 dollars for
something like that and i go
oh so you guys are a scam
i literally i was like oh so you guys
are
scamming people out of their money i go
uh no thanks i can figure this out on my
own and i just hung up
and it wasn't to like
almost like eight or nine years later
that i went and i was like
oh yeah all these people do this they
all had to pay yeah lorraine newman went
through class the groundlings and like
jesus well she didn't go through she was
a founding member but like
you know i just read something uh
in
judd apatow's book
he has a new book he read the old one
right what was that called sick sick in
the head second yeah sicker in the head
so i got a preview and i was reading the
will farrell
uh interview and he just like
he was at usc and he was you know he
didn't really know what he said i'm
going to try comedy
three years at groundlings snl yeah
for someone yeah he and he had no fear
because his dad was like he's like you
know what i don't know i've never really
done comedy well you know what most
people you'll probably fail at it but so
why not do it you know you'll probably
fail you'll find something else to do
yeah so he figured [ __ ] it and that was
kind of his mentality yeah but what were
you doing were you ex were you thinking
i'm gonna be somebody here so
you